good morning John's day after Halloween
I don't like scary things very much but
I did recently go see movie gravity
which was I terrifying I went to see it
with Henry from minutephysics and Derek
from veritasium and yes for a brief
period after the movie we did discuss
how it violated the laws of physics
couple times kind of annoying talk about
that on scishow you can go watch
remember the less obviously very great
movie and we spend more time talking
about the actual terrifying real-life
space disasters that Betty astronauts
and cosmonauts have gone through I made
up not fictional and the spirit of
Halloween let's talk about that the real
terrifying terrifying nough subspace for
example we all know that Neil Armstrong
is a badass but did you know that in
1966 he was piloting Gemini 8 which got
a maneuvering thrusters stuck on and it
started to spin and spin and spin faster
died were within seconds of passing out
because of the extreme g-forces the
thing was spinning up more than one
rotation per second we Neil Armstrong
managed to get it under control because
he's amazing before that in 1965 Alexei
Leonov was the first person to ever do a
spacewalk in a outer space suit however
when he want to get back at the capsule
he couldn't fit his spacesuit had
inflated two months oh I guess I'll just
never go home instead what he did is he
vented his space suit into space until
he's shrunk enough he was suffering from
the bends in the cramped capsule and so
it took a little longer than they
thought to get back in the atmosphere so
they ended way of course in a freezing
cold forest they opened it up and found
that they were pretty much surrounded by
wolves so they just stayed in the
capsule until somebody came to rescue
them Soyuz five was sent back for
re-entry with a single cosmonaut inside
Boris Valen all the service module which
was supposed to detached didn't detach
and so the thing went into the
atmosphere nose-first with the hatch
slowly burning through luckily the
service module burned away and it
righted itself why but then the
parachute didn't deploy correctly and
neither did the landing rockets fire so
he landed so hard that he broke his
teeth also no one knew where he was so
he got out and walked several kilometers
in negative 36 degrees Fahrenheit to a
peasant's house to say hey I'm a
cosmonaut my teeth are broken can I
sleep here the Russian space program man
Wow even scarier Soyuz 18 a named 18a by
the way because they only named
successful missions in Russia they just
call it 18 a
doesn't quite count as a mission because
when it was taken off a separation
failure caused the rocket to totally
turn and point itself toward the ground
the cosmonauts inside the capsule
experience g-forces of Oh 21 GS which is
like 3 G's away from lethal ugly the
capsule figured out something was wrong
the abort sequence started and it
flipped off despite the fact that it was
going toward the ground extremely
quickly the parachutes actually held
however then it landed on the side of a
snowy mountain uh and then slowly began
to roll down the mountain toward a
400-foot cliff it stopped like 20 feet
away because it's parachute again save
them by getting tangled in vegetation
and it continues Soyuz 23 crashed
through the surface of a frozen lake and
the cosmonauts had to stay down there
for nine hours before they got rescued
in the bottom of a lake tear Apollo
13 very well known story harrowing
experience but did you know that Apollo
12 also almost ended in disaster when it
was struck by lightning twice during
launch so much everything could be think
of going wrong has gone wrong in space
fires in space spacecraft being
depressurized spacesuits being
pressurized there was guy who poked a
hole in his hand but he survived two
most recent terrifying near-miss was
when Luca parmitano spacesuit
malfunction and started dumping water
that he was supposed to be drinking into
his helmet filling up his helmet with
water in space no I don't want to drown
in space scarier than any ghost story
you're gonna hear on Halloween thanks
everyone for submitting your nerdy
pumpkins to the nerdfighter pumpkin
carving contest where you could win a
book from my shelf inscribed to you by
me please now go and look at all the
ones that have been submitted and vote
on your favorite week we will tally up
the most voted on ones and they will get
the prizes John thanks for sharing this
week and I'll see you on Tuesday
you
medically speaking starvation occurs
when a body doesn't get enough calories
in nutrients